WORKING ON MIKKO KOSKINEN TO GET
HIM SET FOR TONIGHT'S START
AGAINST THE
BRADY TKACHUK OVER THE LINE WITS
FROM BEING TOGETHER
RACING DOWN THE RIGHT-HAND SIDE.
THAT WILL BE OFF THE POWER
THEY GOTOT
ON THE ENTRIES.
FOEGELE WIT
CURLED, REBOUND WAS TO NICK
PAUL.
SCREEN THERE.
JUST STAYS UP THE ICE.
SURRENDER THE FIRST GOAL, LOUIE.
THAT KIND OF CANCELLED OUT BY
TH THE SENS YOU THROUGH
THE MIDDLE.
ADAM
LOOKING TO MOVET ON THE LINE B
CODY CECI AFTER THAT TO MAKE
SURE HE GETS IT BY THAT
HE'LL TAKE A SPIN.
HASN'T SCORED A POWER PASSING
OPPORTUNITIES THROUGH.
GREAT STICKS, YOU CAN SEE THE  .
BOUCHARD LETS IT GO THROUGH.
TAPPED
AS BRADY TKACHUK PLAYS I'M NOT
SURE YOU ARE 100% OF THE SENS
THE OILERS HAVE THE PENALTY
KILL.
CHIPPED
FIRST. -21 GOAL
DIFFERENTIAL IN THE THIRD WE HAD
ALLUDED TOIRST BISHOP.
A
CENTERING PASS INSIDE TO CHABOT.
COULDN'T HANDLDLNCE FOR MURRAY
ONE.
AN
AND THE OTTAWA SENATORSEFLECTED.
NURSE, WITH THE LEAD FROM
LAST OVERTIME
GOAL.
RIGHT HERE, WINS THAT RACE.
PROTECTS.
HE KNOWS DRAISAITL's
CHABOT, COULDN'T GET AROUND
HYMAN.
WAITS FOR HELP.
STÜTZLE, HEADS FOR THE NET.
SHOT